des pièces ici et pas là on fait ce
qu'on veut
je prends du perrier me le mettre sur la
tête je vais faire du série sauf moi
cani quand je vois tes yeux
ainsi je suis amoureux est ce que je
fais quand tu marches comme un chat je
voudrais alors on a quelques amis tout
de suite mais
alors on a le rythme on a le groove tu
veux je peux pas de toi ken block le
banc
[Applaudissements]
tu vas me quitter son retour et laura
aura deux fois plus de cas ni ce soir il
va bien maintenant et viendra bien sûr à
20h50
en fin d'émission c'est camille combal
hochart et bim bimbadaboum et toi là que
j'arrive ses pouces toilettes je
l'aimais et je me fous badji lacoste au
pouce d'accord il a passé deux jours
avec moi voilà alors quand même fait je
peux vous dire la vérité
c'est ici il n'est pas dans les
émissions puis en armes et en logements
bien des boyaux il ya des galères la
vérité parce qu'on vous dit où est
tournée des émissions mais camille voilà
il ya des courants idéologiques idée
cobb et met en confiance avant
l'émission a vu ses bois en fait sans de
gris gris quartz ok mais là il a bien ce
que c'est cette voix des jeunes allez
vous rappelons qu'amy camille c'est ma
patte de lapin
ouais voilà là je me dis et il était la
mi temps l'agent déconner avant
l'émission
voilà tranquille et voilà il prévoit
dans la lumière puis je rentre chez moi
alors aux 4000 à saint paul a plus que
toi tu puncture sens mieux
ouais ça va toujours du côté salah et
ouais et la laver gens qui me plaisait
c'est les soucis on est en bas moi je
pars mais camille combal reste émissions
continuent bon allez je dois partir sur
ces fonds nous c'est cadeau
mais ne demandez par les filles
est pas là on fait ce qu'on veut
je prends du perrier me le mettre sur la
tête je veux faire du solide et durable
les avis il est temps de dire bonsoir
j'ai c'est là que quelques minutes merci
a évidemment tous les chroniqueurs tout
le public était là vous tous devant vous
je veux prouver cyril évidemment sera
grands ont très vite à sa place et c'est
parce qu'il est en direct tout de suite
c'est un don
j'ai toujours rêvé de faire la télé
c'est que dollar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]